Australian officials say police have
arrested 24 people on arson charges in
connection with the deadly bushfire
sweeping large areas of that country
victims of those fires are returning to
their neighborhoods and seeing the
destruction firsthand Jamie yuccas is in
kiya New South Wales Jamie good morning
how bad is it there
good morning the reality of the
situation is starting to sink in this is
one of nearly 2,000 homes destroyed
firefighters have been battling the
blazes here in southeastern Australia
for nearly five months and as more
destruction is unveiled it shows a
nation in crisis
hundreds of Australians are starting to
sift through the rubble of their still
smoldering homes returning to
smog-filled towns I couldn't say the
smoke was so thick and empty stores they
evacuated the tourists that's without
income which is all that cream and that
profit thousands have been left homeless
many in rural areas have spent days
without electricity and drinking water
now record high temperatures and severe
drought are making it tough to battle
the unprecedented bush fires one of the
biggest challenges for fire officials
right now is this giant plume of smoke
that's hampering air operations near the
port of Eden in New South Wales as the
fire roared through this logging
community it started 75,000 tons worth
of wood chips on fire it could now take
weeks to put out but Australian
firefighters won't be battling the
flames alone on Monday a crew of 20
veteran firefighters from California who
fought some of the state's most
devastating wildfires suited up and
shipped out to Melbourne we're
definitely there to represent the United
States Forest Service
Lenard d'emic oolong in is in charge of
the crew getting along with fellow
firefighters from another country state
it kind of goes hand in hand those
California firefighters are expected to
be here in southeastern Australia
helping with the fire fight for at least
the next month and many are concerned
going into the weekend with higher
temperatures and stronger winds
predicted for CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Kaia Australia
Thank You Jamie nice to see the u.s.
helping out there
you